Welcome to the Man of Recaps.
This is your complete Marvel recap
for The Marvels.
We begin with the first Captain Marvel.
We meet an apparently human woman, who's
an elite warrior in the alien Kree empire.
She has no memory of her past life,
so she thinks her name is Vers.
The Kree are at war with the evil
shapeshifting Skrulls,
and during a battle, Vers
crash lands on Earth, back in the 90’s!
She teams up with SHIELD agent young Nick Fury,
and fills him in about the Skrull threat.
But soon Vers uncovers the mysteries of
her past...
she is a human, Carol Danvers.
She was a fighter pilot testing a new super engine
built with the Tesseract, the Space Stone.
But the Kree tried to steal it so Carol crashed, the engine exploded,
and blasted her with super space powers!
So Carol realizes
the Kree have been lying to her all along,
and they meet with the Skrull leader
Talos, who's like
“Yeah, no, they're the bad guys, we're the good guys.”
So Carol Danvers reclaims her identity,
changes her uniform from the Kree colors to the good old U.S. Air Force.
Carol teams up with her old pilot
best friend Maria Rambeau,
who's got a young daughter, Monica.
They also recruit the cat, Goose,
who is an alien Flerken, woah! Watch out for that.
And when he scratches Nick Fury’s
eye, yep, that's how he lost it.
As they fight to stop the Kree invasion,
soon Carol realizes the chip they put on her to help control
her powers...
was suppressing her powers!
She rips it off and oh she's glowing...
Goes full Super Saiyan!
Captain Marvel unleashed!
She flies around in space shooting energy beams,
takes out the whole Kree fleet singlehandedly.
But Carol can't stick around on Earth,
she's got to fly off
and keep fighting the Kree.
But she gives Nick Fury her beeper number,
like “Hit me up if there’s a real emergency.”
That emergency happened in Avengers: Infinity War,
when Thanos snapped away half the population.
Nick Fury’s last move was to send that text,
so in Avengers: Endgame, Captain Marvel
showed up!
And helped kick Thanos' butt.
Let's do a quick recap on Secret Invasion,
in case any of it comes up.
Nick Fury became good friends
with the Skrull leader Talos,
but a bad Skrull, Gravik, takes over,
and he wants to conquer Earth,
and oh! He kills Talos.
Gravik got the DNA of a bunch of super people,
wants to put it all in himself
to be the Super Skrull.
But Talos had a daughter, G’iah,
and she blasts herself  with the super DNA, too...
so they have a Super Skrull fight!
The strongest of her powers
is Captain Marvel, So blam!
Kamehameha! Defeats King Piccolo.
Now it's time for Wandavision.
Long story short, Wanda Maximoff, The Scarlet Witch,
lost control of her powers, and turned this entire small town into a sitcom,
where she and Vision
could live happily ever after.
So we follow Agent Monica Rambeau,
yes Maria's daughter from Captain Marvel.
She travels into the Hex to find out
what's going on.
But Wanda soon spots
the imposter and kicks her back out.
But Monica's not quitting,
she's going in again.
Which the science people warn her
could be real dangerous.
Indeed, she makes it through,
but it did something weird to her...
Now she's got some super powers!
At the end she's approached by Skrulls,
who invite her to space for a secret
mission.
They're working with Nick Fury
to build a space station called Saber.
And now it's time for Ms. Marvel.
Kamala Khan is a normal teenage girl
who is a Captain Marvel super fan.
She's going to spice up her cosplay
with her grandma's old bangle...
But when she puts it on, woah what’s this?
It unlocks her superpowers!
Turns out her grandma was a Djinn,
an interdimensional super person.
Her science friend tells her
that her genes have a “mutation”...
Yeah the first M-bomb in the MCU!
Eventually the X-Men are coming!
But for now Kamala protects Jersey City
as the minor superhero Nightlight,
and she saves the world from her evil
Djinn Auntie.
Then her mom sews her a better super suit,
and she learns how to master her powers.
So she takes a new name from her idol,
Captain Marvel, and becomes Ms. Marvel!
And in fact they do have
a strange connection,
because at the end
she's teleported away...
She swapped places with Captain Marvel!
So Carol Danvers finds herself
in a teenager's bedroom in New Jersey,
and The Marvels will pick up there.
If you like this recap, hit that Subscribe button
for more of the best recaps of TV and movies.